rich you're up buddy
good name
thanks guys all right so what is the
solution to this problem
okay um i think the former the
craigslist
understand the problem that we're going
into
so um at the moment there's all this
push for this green equitable world
revolution thing that's happening
uh and and the problem is we're about to
be caught off guard by it
since
there is a theory going around the
internet i don't know if you guys have
seen it but it's based on us hitting a
certain epoch in climate cycles
so
in canada north america
denmark um greenland and britain the
weather has got all wacky in strange
patterns um
and they're trying to claim that there's
food problems but the food problems are
based on supply but i'm not so sure that
that is the case
because there's a lot of things that
seem to correlate and some of the
predictions some people be making
specifically the ice age farmers seems
pretty reliable
okay you're you're kind of zipping
around here a little bit so let me just
bring you back to the point so
like what is the solution to the
problems facing the west right now
um
because i think when the food supply
goes and they try and push this bug
protein and
and uh protein paste and whatnot i think
this political activism is going to
disappear because
people are going to get sick and
malnourished from them okay but that's
not an active solution that's that's
that's a passive sit back and watch this
unfold sort of statement i i don't think
it's passive because it's
it's pretty hard to to get prepared and
to start like um
acquiring skills for a more agrarian
economy and particularly an indoor
agrarian economy is
quite difficult because you have to
marshal like money from crypto
into some farmland somewhere and you
have to you have to build a local
network up because we're going to get
locked down right like they're going to
lock downs they can lock us down again
there's going to be very little access
to food so we're going to have to rely
on people locally so we've got to start
getting ahead of this and building the
networks now because if we say
there's going to be okay so
you're you're leaning into the future
making a prediction about a problem that
doesn't exist right now we don't have
food source shortage problems there's no
issues with food right now we've got
other problems that we're dealing with
so i mean
what is the solution to the problem that
we have today is what i'm asking
well i think you've got to break the
kids out of their woke activism because
okay so what is what is the solution to
unwoking children
when the entire school system is
designed to wokify your kids and most
parents today i mean like one of the
biggest things that you can do that's
detrimental to your kids is put them in
the elementary school system or in
daycare especially if you have a small
child like
the like putting a three or four year
old into a daycare system while you go
to work to go and make your 50 000 a
year to pay for the day care system is
the equivalence of essentially child
abuse i mean you're doing your child a
disservice you're supposed to raise your
kid yourself this is what most people do
today right so how do you unwoke these
children
i think you have to
both scare them but also give them a
better a better idea of the future they
want to be in which is probably
more back to nature and with the animals
and stuff right but i mean you can't
unwoke all the children a parent can
unwoke their own child how do they do
that they homeschool them they make sure
that they're under their wing until
they're an adult and they give them all
the necessary tools and resources but
the vast majority of the population as i
pointed out here let's go back to
exhibit a because i'm going to keep
going back this because i think voting
patterns is very important the vast
majority of the population supports
you know we're talking 60
70 80 like we're talking about 80
of the canadian population anyway
supports the system as it stands right
now so that doesn't solve anything if
let's say let's say five or ten percent
of the north american population home
schools or kids
un unvocifies them you know gives them
all the tools and resources tells them
you know teaches them how to hunt and
trap and and grow their own food
and not not deal with the cairns and the
political correctness and all that other
nonsense you're still not going to solve
the problem so that's still not a
solution
well i guess i'm i'm i'm betting on
certain things happening and i'm trying
to get ahead of them
so
i think the vaccine passport so hope so
hope is your plan is what you're saying
well i i guess hope is a terrible plan
how many times have i said hope is a
terrible plan rich
well it's i'm not the future isn't
exactly optimistic in my my world view
but um i i think if
if we are locked down to smaller
communities it gives us a chance to
actually walk out and meet people and
start planning okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna switch you out
because i got like the entire areas
waiting here for people to chime in
we're not getting to a specific solution
but i want to thank you for chiming in
though but one thing could you could you
check out the ice age farmer and just
keep an eye on things he's saying that
the ice age farmer what is that is that
a youtube is that a website
uh well his telegram is less censored so
you could check that out but you can
probably find them on youtube or bit
shoot about it okay thanks for the shout
out appreciate it
you